[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo nos
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
los migrantes refugiados desplazados y
solicitantes de asilo son personas
especialmente vulnerables el estar lejos
de casa y haber enfrentado situaciones
traumáticas que los obligaron a huir
dejan huellas físicas y psicológicas
difíciles de superar muchas veces las
consecuencias visibles son las primeras
en recibir atención dejando de lado la
salud mental para tratar a los
refugiados integralmente la cruz roja
trabaja con los niños desplazados en
áfrica el apoyo psicológico se presta
una vez por semana en pro del bienestar
mental de los más pequeños así lo hacen
en la república centroafricana años de
violencia que dejan cicatrices
psicológicas en las historias de miedo y
tristeza abundan entre estos desplazados
en la república centroafricana
y los niños a su corta edad ya saben lo
que es perder a un ser querido a causa
de la guerra para intentar sanar esas
heridas la cruz roja abrió un centro de
asesoramiento para los más pequeños
principal humo las emociones más comunes
son la tristeza el miedo y la ira la ocu
le implique un viga termo es fundamental
involucrar a los padres para que
comprendan lo que les pasa a sus hijos y
puedan decirnos qué signos de trauma
muestra andic y con sido y true machismo
romaric realiza trabajo psicosocial en
este refugio son sesiones individuales
en las que se mezclan el dibujo la
respiración y el diálogo para lograr
objetivos acaban de perder a su padre y
los pensamientos oscuros han regresado
ir al centro de asesoramiento les ayuda
mucho que escuchen los consejos que
reciben y se comportan de manera
diferente en casa por tradición los
chamanes y curanderos son son los que
tratan los problemas psicológicos aquí
sin embargo han permitido que los
tratamientos modernos complementen su
trabajo eso me anima mucho ver que los
primeros programas están comenzando a
funcionar
y le dije porque es cierto que en el
pasado quizás le prestamos mucha
atención al aspecto físico pedíamos
heridas físicas y las tratamos pero no
vimos lo invisible de una pavlik la
discípula más de 200.000 personas han
huido de sus ciudades desde que estalló
la violencia el pasado diciembre por el
resultado de las elecciones en el país
algunos cruzaron fronteras y se
instalaron en camerún chad y la
república democrática del congo
en el último año el kobe 19 se convirtió
en una preocupación adicional para los
que están lejos de casa la pérdida de un
ser querido el aislamiento y el trabajo
en línea también afecta la salud mental
de los migrantes ese es el caso de
gabriela castillo una mexicana a la que
la pandemia la sorprendió a miles de
kilómetros de su hogar ahora recibe
apoyo psicológico gracias a la ayuda de
sus compatriotas en francia el informe
desde erika olavarría el grafiti que
está al frente del departamento de
gabriel en el centro de parís parece
enviarle un mensaje
la mexicana estudiante de posgrado lleva
siete meses en francia cuando comenzó la
crisis sanitaria de repente la vida en
pandemia lejos de su país se le volvió
cuesta arriba el estrés por los exámenes
afectó aún más su situación
todo se fue juntando cuando después del
verano reforzaron las medidas sanitarias
pues bueno esta incertidumbre también de
que parece que no termina un poco la
emergencia sanitaria fue una cosa que
sumó tuve periodos de insomnio tenía
taquicardia por ejemplo
pues una sensación de presión en el
pecho las emociones como a flor de piel
gabriel es una de los 6000 mexicanos
registrados en los consulados de trance
y mónaco para ellos la delegación
diplomática organizó un servicio inédito
de terapia gratuita junto a la
asociación franco-mexicana de
psiquiatría
disponible en español y hasta por
teléfono como gabriel a más de 60
personas han sido atendidas estos
últimos meses a la vez más mexicanos
particularmente jóvenes no se escribían
que se sentían solo se sentían mal se
sentían deprimidos al cabo de los meses
vimos que otra otro grupo social de
mexicanos en francia estaban siendo
también víctimas producto de la de la
crisis de agresiones físicas aversiones
sexuales que son las mujeres
mujeres maltratadas estudiantes ana
maría lópez esta psicóloga mexicana en
parís reside entre 4 o 5 pacientes
nuevos por semana desde el comienzo de
la pandemia
la mayoría hispanohablantes en francés
muchísimo psicólogos se le da mucha
prioridad la salud mental pero nissan no
es lo mismo ir con alguien que hable tu
idioma a alguien que además tenga los
códigos culturales de alguna manera creo
que es más liberador el proceso
terapéutico es no sé si más eficiente
pero la gente se siente más entendida y
entonces la gente se siente mejor si un
consejo les puedo dar es no sufran en
silencio todo pasa y no se alejen de la
gente que los quiere es lo que hizo
gabriela que comienza nuevamente a
caminar con paso firme
[Música]
la respuesta a las necesidades de los
migrantes y refugiados deben contemplar
soluciones duraderas y sostenibles es
por eso que la salud mental debe ser
también parte de la agenda y el dato de
migración de la semana jordania abrió el
primer centro de vacunación del mundo
contra el cob y 19 en un campo de
refugiados se ubica en el campamento
desatar y que acoge a unas 80.000
personas bellas 2000 se inscribieron en
una primera etapa para recibir la dosis
la apertura del centro llega cuando
organizaciones de derechos humanos
llaman a los gobiernos de los países de
acogida para que incluyan a los
migrantes refugiados y solicitantes de
asilo en sus programas de inoculación
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan conectados con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]